le thème cette année ce sont les marais
leur biodiversité yvelines environnement
relançons concours le 28e destiné aux
jeunes âgés de 5 à 15 ans le jeu et mis
en place avec l'éducation nationale
il peut se faire en classe aux familles
ou entre amis c'est une grille quêtes à
remplir notre bulle n'est pas la
difficulté mais bien au contraire que ça
soit une réflexion autour d'un thème
donné et pour ça on espère que peut-être
les parents liront ce que font les
enfants et à travers les enfants aussi
nous atteindrons les parents
parmi les partenaires la sncf l'institut
national de recherche agroalimentaire
l'office national des forêts ou encore
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
en plus cette année c'est un sujet qui
nous tient à coeur nous on est sur une
grande zone humide on est sur l'étang de
saint quentin en yvelines
on ad mare juste à côté on a on a
beaucoup de grandes richesses de
biodiversité et les marées les zones
humides ont été un peu mise de côté
après guerre cette biodiversité si les
mares disparaissait on disparaissait
avec les participants ont jusqu'au 1er
avril pour envoyer leurs grilles la
remise des prix aura lieu le 16 mai
prochain à versailles